mesdames et messieurs bonsoir comme
chaque année ce 1er mai était la journée
du muguet on en a vendu à tous les
carrefours ils étaient beaux ils sont
est bon il nous apporter des parfums de
sous bois
il y avait du beau nantes et
particulièrement aux différents à froid
francs lebrun en général pas plus cher
que l'an passé et du muguet sauvage mais
aux clochettes minuscule alors comme
celui des sauvages était vraiment un peu
petit à cause du mauvais temps qu'il a
fait depuis quelques semaines deux
jeunes ramasseurs venue du midi
l'entouraient souvent de thym et de
romarin
sur quoi leur muguet porte bonheur santé
bon toute la provence mais en vain c'est
bien le but nantais qui a été le plus
acheté par les passants le commando qui
détient toujours une vingtaine d'otages
de l'ambassade d'iran à londres à
prolonger l'ultimatum qu'il avait
adressée aux autorités iraniennes et qui
se termine est d'abord aujourd'hui m
les négociations sont à l'heure actuelle
au point mort tout à l'heure monsieur
bani sadr le président de l'iran a
déclaré refuser catégoriquement de se
plier aux conditions du commando je vous
rappelle que les trois auteurs de la
prise d'otage sont des iraniens
originaire de la province pétrolière du
khouzistan mais appartenant à la
minorité arabe qui conteste l'autorité
de l'ayatollah khomeini il demande que
91 eur compatriote emprisonnée en iran
par les gardiens de la révolution soient
libérés le commando disait jean prolongé
son ultimatum puis à londres
de violentes bagarres ont éclaté aux
abords de l'ambassade
gérard ce bac notre envoyé spécial nous
présente son reportage sur cette journée
pleine de paix c'est toujours la même
attente devant l'ambassade d'iran à
londres
la tactique d inspecteur de scotland
yard est simple il essaie par la
persuasion et la négociation continue
d'obtenir la libération des otages sans
effusion de sang
cependant depuis quelques instants les
effectifs de police ont nettement plus
important est maintenant kensington road
cette route qui longe high park et
l'ambassade d'iran et est complètement
obstruée par des camions de la police et
ne sais pas ce que prépare derrière
les hommes de la spéciale branche cette
brigade antiterroriste britannique
comme toujours dans ce genre d'affaires
les policiers et les négociateurs
spécule beaucoup sur la détermination
des terroristes et tout cela face à une
impassible statut dans le célèbre jardin
de hyde park de monte une étrange mais
loupé
maintenu à 200 mètres de l'ambassade par
un cordon de policiers ce sont des
fidèles de khomeiny les étudiants
iraniens qui depuis hier soir sans
discontinuer tourner en rond et scandent
des slogans favorables à la révolution
islamique est contre cette prise d'otage
ces iraniens sont disposés à se
sacrifier pour prendre d'assaut
l'ambassade et chante khomeiny nous
sommes tes soldats jusqu'à la dernière
goutte de sang si les canaux de la
flotte américaine nous ont pas fait
bouger et même pas effrayés
ce n'est pas trois pistolets qui nous
vaincrons j'estime que si des diplômes à
d'innocents sont ainsi tués
la responsabilité en incombera au
gouvernement britannique
c'est à lui de prendre des mesures
adéquates les londoniens d'abord diverti
commencent à être excédés et certains
ont lancé cet après midi des cris
hostiles tels que rentrez chez vous et
ayatollahs va te faire voir la position
officielle du gouvernement britannique
est elle plus délicate car de l'autre
côté les terroristes ont fait déclaré
par la voix d'un officier de police de
scotland yard que si téhéran n'acceptait
pas la négociation
l'ayatollah khomeini porterait l'entière
responsabilité de la mort des otages
un moyen pour le gouvernement de londres
de montrer qu'ils ne sont pas en mesure
de continuer la négociation tant que le
gouvernement iranien se refusera tout
dialogue
double pression sur le gouvernement de
madame thatcher celle des terroristes et
celle de l'ayatollah dont les partisans
mais porte parole cinq fois par jour
comme le veut l'islam pris à la oak bord
sur kensington road scotland yard va
pourtant être obligé de prendre une
décision car elle ne peut maintenir
ainsi un tel dispositif et surtout ne
rien proposer aux taureaux rist qui
peuvent d'un moment à l'autre
mettre à exécution leur menace tuer tous
les otages et faire sauter l'ambassade à
paris il y a eu plusieurs défilés
syndicaux du 1er mai puisque sa famille
l'unité d'action n'avait pas pu se faire
et les quatre principaux ont été dans
l'ordre où nous allons vous les
présenter en images est faute de la
bastille au père lachaise
lavez les récents de l'éducation
nationale également vers le père
lachaise ce site dans la matinée et dans
l'après midi à partir de 14h la cfdt
entre de santé et la bastille et la cgt
entre la place de la république et le
carrefour richelieu drouot c'est la
première fois depuis neuf ans que ces
défilés du 1er mai ne se font pas dans
l'unité
patrice et costes et isabelle richter
ont suivi pour nous ces diverses
manifestations
10h ce matin le cortège de force
ouvrière s'est rendu au cimetière du
père lachaise pour déposer une gerbe au
mur des fédérés conduite par monsieur
jean françois forget secrétaire général
de l'organisation régionale
on estime à 3000 le nombre de ceux qui
ont répondu à l'appel de fo
monsieur bergeron qui était lui à
montpellier a lancé un appel en faveur
de la cohésion de l'europe et a de
nouveau abordé le problème de la
sécurité sociale qu'on ne règlera pas
selon lui à coup de slogans
la cérémonie au par la chaise s'est
achevée par un hommage à léo jour au
premier président de fo et gestion des
fédérations d'éducation nationale soit
une centaine de personnes sont allées
elle aussi déposé une gerbe au père
lachaise
andré henry le secrétaire général a
déclaré je cite la classe des
travailleurs est avide de rassemblement
et de fraternité la scène continuera ses
efforts pour préparer le rassemblement
syndical
des délégations de cette organisation
ont d'ailleurs tenu à participer l'après
midi au défilé de la cgt et de la cfdt
15 heures place de la république c'est
le taux de la cgt qui a réussi à
rassembler un grand nombre de
sympathisants
on me les primes uniques ton il avait
des premiers mais comme des jours ils se
suivent mais ne se ressemblent pas celui
ci n'a pu être organisée par l'unité tu
aurais souhaité les travailleurs cela
tient à des réalités qui serait vain de
chercher à dissimuler qui éloigne
l'unité d'action des syndicalistes
estiment entre la crise du capitalisme
doit ainsi paix à la modération
revendicative et à la limitation de
l'action
pas de question pour la cgt de sacrifier
les revendications et l'action des
travailleurs à une unité de façade dans
l'essonne et l'isère selon pouvoir et le
patronat
et georges séguy de continuer il est des
moments de la lutte des classes où la
meilleure façon de servir dignité c'est
encore de promouvoir l'action est de
proposer une grève générale pour le 13
mai prochain
trente mille personnes auraient donc
manifesté dans le cortège pas de
dirigeants socialistes
une délégation du parti communiste
français slogans comme banderole
concerné en majorité les grandes
revendications actuelles bas salaires
réduction du temps de travail liberté et
le refus du consensus social très
nombreuses les délégations de
travailleurs immigrés
la cfdt quant à elle a fait partir son
cortège du métro sentier pour mettre
l'accent sur le sort des travailleurs de
la confection étrangers et mal rémunérés
pour la plupart les immigrés ont
d'ailleurs manifesté en très grand
nombre jusqu'à la bastille mais le
défilé avait beau réunir dix à quinze
mille personnes ce qui est beaucoup pour
la cfdt tous les cédétistes n'y était
pas certains s'étaient en effet réunis
derrière la banderole unité d'action qui
souhaitaient un parcours commun avec la
cgt
finalement les partisans de l'unité se
sont joints les filets les cfdt sans
problème les grandes vedettes de la
manifestation était sans conteste est
mitoyen du micro qui ont enfin vu
satisfaire leurs revendications
ce 1er mai va être un peu illuminée pour
nous je crois que pour les travailleurs
immigrés en france par la bonne victoire
des nettoyeurs du métro car plus de cinq
semaines de grève dans l'unité dans la
combativité
tu dois dire le sérieux ont permis
d'obtenir un succès important la
garantie de l'emploi et une amélioration
des salaires du pouvoir d'achat qui sera
quand même de plus de 10% cette année et
de 20% avec l'année prochaine on a gagné
c'est à dire pendant la grève d'une
touche de 1350 et maintenant on était
chanteuse demi
2000 à près de 1600 - 15 jan
un peu partout dans le cortège les
militants regrettait amèrement la
désunion de ce 1er mai 81 et ils ont
vivement applaudi plus tard edmond maire
au cours de son discours de la bastille
quand il a appelé à l'unité syndicale et
annoncé une action commune avec la cgt
et la scène le 13 mai prochain sur le
thème de la protection sociale
nous reviendrons à la fin de ce journal
sur la question du métro un peu plus
longuement et cela dit vous l'avez vu il
ya une cinquième manifestation quelque
5000 personnes réclamant l'unité
syndicale cgt cfdt ont marché
aujourd'hui à la rencontre des cortèges
de deux grandes centrales syndicales qui
manifestaient nous venons de le dire
ces packs à moscou le 1er mai a été
marqué par un long défilé place rouge
sans éléments militaires contrairement à
l'an passé par la réapparition de
monsieur brejnev rentré de vacances en
très bonne forme tombe et il est par
l'absence d'un certain nombre
d'ambassadeurs occidentaux dans les
tribunes de moscou va être envoyé
spécial bruno end
alors nous revenons à paris une autre
manifestation manifestation un book sont
pas souvent aujourd'hui a eu lieu devant
l'ambassade du rss dans le 16e
arrondissement organisée à l'appel du
comité des droits de l'homme moscou 81
parmi les animateurs marek halter et
bernard henri lévy et cette
manifestation ayant été interdite ce qui
prenait part se sont rendues devant
l'ambassade d'argent
11h30 les manifestants réunis en sit in
devant l'ambassade du rss à paris sont
violemment interpellé par la police
le quartier est bouclé par d'importantes
forces de l'ordre
les journalistes sont bousculés andré
glucksmann l'historien jean et
d'einstein et leonid push sont jetés
dans un car l'ambassade du rss et
d'argentine avait été choisi comme
symbole par les manifestants comme deux
pays où sont bafoués des droits de
l'homme pourquoi s'interdisant de
l'homme ils n'ont rien cassé il est
assis gentiment j'étais témoin j'ai garé
ma voiture pour voir ce qui s'est passé
en a sauté sur des gens qui thaci et
sans défense et niort mai
12h15 conduit au commissariat du xvième
arrondissement la trentaine de
manifestants interpellés se libère en
brisant les vitres du car et en forçant
la porte puis rejoint un autre groupe
réunis devant l'ambassade d'argentine à
l'occasion de la 85e manifestation
hebdomadaire en faveur des prisonniers
politiques disparus dans ce pays
13 heures la manifestation se disperse
sans incident sion et la répression de
cette manifestation est un peu
surprenante parce que quelle est la
raison la raison que l'on a donné c'est
que le 1er mai réservé aux
manifestations d'ordre syndical et pas
aux manifestations pour les droits de
l'homme
or le 1er mai à l'origine c'est une
manifestation dans internationale qui
symbolise la volonté des travailleurs de
tous les travailleurs et partiellement
des travailleurs les plus exploités dans
le monde de retrouver leur dignité
d'hommes leur dignité d'hommes libres
donc le 1er mai et bien justement une
grande fête des droits de l'homme
surtout au moment où on apprend qu'au
brésil par exemple et au chili on arrête
actuellement des dizaines de dirigeants
syndicaux
surtout au moment où on apprend qu en
union soviétique des militants d'aidés
des simples ouvriers qui veulent
constituer un syndicat vraiment libre
vraiment indépendants sont jetés en
prison et on n'en parle pas beaucoup et
d'ailleurs hier justement la veille du
jour où ces gens manifestaient pour les
droits de l'homme
argentine union soviétique a été publié
un rapport par amnistie internationale
que va publier d'ailleurs les éditions
mozarine un gros rapport de 200 pages
sur le problème de la répression l'union
soviétique c'est qu'ainsi international
est une organisation qui ne fait pas de
différence selon les violations des
droits de l'homme à l'est ou à l'ouest
et qui a jamais été pris en défaut et on
y apprend qu'il ya effectivement une
union soviétique actuellement derrière
souffler le paravent de c2c grand défilé
de ces grandes manifestations il ya une
aggravation par exemple alors qu'en
quatre ans 400 personnes ont été
arrêtées pour délit d'opinion ou
religieux il semble que ces six derniers
mois
cent personnes ont été arrêtées en six
mois pour simple délit politique voilà
d'ailleurs leur nom sur fait cadeau
c'est la liste qu'a publié amnistie
internationale des 100 personnes dont on
est sûr y en a sans doute plus mais dont
les sûr qu'ils ont été arrêtés et puis
bien sûr ce n'est pas du tout la terreur
stalinienne ça n'a rien à voir ce qui se
passe à qui on est ce qui se passait
sous ben ali mais quand même amnistie
internationale pour la paix
fouad donne des détails qu'on ne
connaissait pas par exemple aucun
acquittement on a pu repérer au qu'un
acquittement pour délits politiques en
union soviétique on est automatiquement
condamnée deuxièmement beaucoup de gens
sont condamnés à aller dans des camps
correctif par le travail
or on a appris que dans ces camps
correctif il ya un système de punition
si par exemple vous ne l'appliqué pas
les normes de travail car on doit
travailler et ces punitions consiste à
les privations de nourriture
la première punition par exemple vous ne
devez plus manger que le correspondent
ce qui correspond à 1300 calories par
jour ce qui représente que les deux
cinquièmes des besoins normaux de
l'homme
et si ça s'aggrave encore les punitions
vous allez au cachot et cette ration qui
est pourtant petit neveu n'est plus
donnée que un jour sur deux donc la fin
est utilisé contre certains dissidents
troisièmement les internements
psychiatriques non seulement ça ne
s'arrête pas mais depuis soixante-quinze
il y as en cassant cas de dissidents
politiques condamnés aux asiles
psychiatriques et écouter quels sont les
motifs les motifs et diagnostic que
donne des médecins d'après ce rapport un
ici internationale on peut être donc
jeté en dans un asile de fous pour
épuisement nerveux causée par une
obsession de justice ou bien encore pour
illusions réformistes ou bien encore
pour manille de reconstruction de la
société
à ce compte il ya des centaines sinon
des milliers de gens qui devraient être
mis dans les asiles psychiatriques en
france et enfin on cite un cas par
exemple d'un procès où un dissident
était jugée et ont demandé qu'il soit
mis noisy psychiatrique alors le juge
demande aux xi cas mais quelle est la
preuve de son délire et le petit cap
diva la preuve de son délire c'est son
attitude anti soviétique et le juge dit
mais quelle forme prend ce délire et le
petit caddie et bien la forme que prend
ce délit ce délire c'est qu'il ne réagit
pas aux traitements et qu'il ne corrige
pas son attitude
voilà des fêtes concrets que l'on trouve
dans ce gros rapport d'amnistié
internationale sur la répression en
union soviétique
merci jean françois kahn moyen-orient
selon un sondage publié à tel-aviv plus
des deux tirs visent israéliens seraient
prêts à faire des concessions
cisjordanie étant bien entendu que la
sécurité d'israël doit être assurée à
l'onu le conseil de sécurité était
saisie d'une résolution tunisienne
prévoyant l'établissement d'un état
palestinien indépendant mais les états
unis ont opposé leur veto il le juste
et si par la nécessité de laisser se
poursuivre le processus de recherche
d'une paix d'ensemble au proche-orient
processus prévu dans les accords wickham
dévide leur représentant monsieur donald
mackenzie a reconnu que cette approche
des choses étaient critiquées mais
l'utiliser 1 seule voie politique
disponibles et dans les couloirs de
l'onu des manifestants avaient pu
tromper la vigilance du service d'ordre
et ils ont jeté divers projectiles dont
des pots de peinture rouge sur
l'ambassadeur américain qui n'a pas prêt
vous le voyez la chose au tragique
il ad'autres préoccupations qu'un peu de
peinture sur son visage et sur ses
méthodes nous vous avons dit tout à
l'heure que la presque totalité des 900
nettoyeur du métro parisien avait
ratifié le protocole d'accord négocié au
cours de pourparlers souvent tendues
avec les sociétés de sous traitance la
ratp
cela met fin à une grève de 39 jours le
travail reprend demain c'est une
occasion pour nous de nous pencher sur
les métiers du nettoyage il groupe à
paris trente mille employés municipaux
dont les éboueurs et les bas des guerres
sans compter d'autres appartenant à des
entreprises privées généralement
employés au nettoyage des locaux tels
que les usines et les bureaux
seul avis 30 millions de français sont
concernés par l'hygiène et par la
propreté de leur lieu de travail qu'il
s'agisse de jeunes d'âge scolaire ou
d'actifs 40 tonnes de compost vendus à
des agriculteurs quittent chaque jour
une petite usine de seine-et-marne leur
destination
les vignobles champenois qu'elle
fertilise rond mais il s'agit là d'un
engrais pas comme les autres puisqu'il
provient des ordures ménagères fournis
par les communes voisines une feinte
bucolique pour une infime partie des
déchets déversés par les habitants de
paris et de sa région
1 million 600 mille tonnes d'ordures
chaque année pour la capitale
si on les empile est le tas serais aussi
haut que la tour eiffel
chaque matin à 9 heures les 5000
éboueurs parisiens employés municipaux
qui ont pris leur travail à 6h terminent
leur tournée ils se rassemblent dans une
centaine de lieux d'appel comme ils
disent disséminés dans paris l'aïe
peuvent prendre une douche et faire une
pause casse-croûte tandis que les
chauffeurs conduisent les bennes
jusqu'aux usines d'incinération oui
brûler la quasi-totalité des ordures
parisienne mais pour les éboueurs
la journée n'est pas finie on est en
route
après on va commencer vers le véritable
et valide émis l'idée est une autre
tournoi y est enterré notre tournée pour
balayer et s'est révélé à jouer et vous
travaillez combien d'heures par semaine
42e ou d'autres encore ont scandé heures
par semaine et pour quel salaire
3 les travailleurs d'origine étrangère
sont nombreux ils sont 48% actuellement
au service du nettoiement pour 52%
français on note cependant qu'il y a
cinq ans la proportion était notablement
différente puisqu'il n'y avait que 28%
les joueurs français
et ce sont les déboires et engrais qui
ne sont pas titulaires et ans j'étais
bien entendu ce sont les éboueurs
étrangers qui ne sont pas titulaires
pour qu'on en voit
parce que pour être fonctionnaire
français contenir de la nationalité
française
titulaires et non titulaires bénéficie
du même salaire et des mêmes avantages
sociaux sauf pour le droit à la retraite
60 ans pour les premiers 65 ans pour les
seconds la propreté c'est aussi le
nettoyage des usines et des durant cette
fois par des entreprises privées
elle emploie des laveurs de carreaux
pour 3500 francs par mois et des
nettoyeuses non spécialisés pour un
salaire horaire de 15 francs le grand
handicap de ces professions elles ne
peuvent travailler qu'en dehors des
heures de bureau
la moyenne en france du temps de travail
de l'ordre de cinq euros car ce que nous
souhaitons faire à cette rencontre
c'est arrivé la faire travailler nos
employés au plan des ouvriers nettoyeur
huit heures d'affilée
seulement il faut changer les mentalités
et en particulier les mentalités de nos
clients
ça n'est pas facile vous savez bien
quand on parle de changer les mentalités
ça ne se fait pas tout de suite
il faudra chose qui semble difficile à
faire accepter par les occupants des
locaux que le ménage se fasse pendant
les heures de bureau
halte à la saleté halte au gaspillage
dans l' usine de recyclage de voir la
ferrière absolument tous les déchets
sont récupérés après avoir été triés
puis brûlé ou voiliers selon les cas à
la sortie du combustible et surtout de
l'engrais pour les champs c'est la
revanche de la campagne sur le lit
l'intersyndicale du pmu avait lancé un
mot d'ordre de grève pour
l'enregistrement des paris ce matin
ainsi dans la région parisienne sur les
600 bureaux qui devait fonctionner sans
prendre seulement ont été ouverts ce qui
a perturbé les perrières dans
l'établissement de leur ticket
quant aux tiers s'est lui même disputé à
saint cloud il a été remporté par le
quatre dom lorenzino à l'écurie fradkov
l'écurie qui ne cesse de gagner devant
le 6ème et le daf lady of camelot ouest
si les rapports 3050 francs dans l'ordre
pour 5 francs dans un ordre différent si
110 francs pour 5 francs un record
le français thierry vigneron du racing
club de france a battu le record
d'europe du saut à la perche avec 5
mètre 67 aujourd'hui à libourne barré
gironde
le précédent record appartenait aux
polonais kazakhe rydzek 5 mètre 66 je
vous rappelle que le record du monde
appartient à l'américain dave roberts
depuis quatre ans avec 5 mètre 70
environ n'est plus qu'à trois
centimètres du record du lycée
ensevelie du patrimoine nous avons
commencé vous vous le rap est une
nouvelle série laissant chef-d'oeuvre
c'est à dire les témoignages de ce qu'a
réalisé le génie français au cours des
dix derniers secteurs
après la tapisserie de bayeux the rain
mathilde voici les vitraux de chartres
chartres depuis des siècles un pool de
la chrétienté sa cathédrale un haut lieu
de l'art médiéval chartres c'est aussi
deux sièges du centre international du
vitrail qui sera inauguré au début de
juillet et qui se propose un programme
fort ambitieux les vitraux de chartres
sont parmi les plus beaux fleurons de
notre patrimoine
mais ce sont des joyaux menacé il faut
bien le dire par la pollution
un reportage de françoise labrousse
où
voilà vous êtes très sensibles à la
beauté des du temps bien écouter oui
c'est une partie de ma vie
ça fait trente trois ans que je
travaille dans cet atelier au pied de la
cathédrale de schmidt a fait au pied et
ce matin c'était encore une joie un
bonheur extrême de venir de mon petit
village et d'apercevoir au delà de
gallardo
c'est admirable cathédrale qui je
l'espère dure encore tellement longtemps
au-dessus des blés des maïs de beauce
pour moi chaque c'est un lieu
extraordinaire enfin il s'est passé là
sur ce même lot ou 12e et au xiiie
siècle
un événement du risque était préparée de
longue date puisque même chez les
druides ont dit qu'il y avait un culte
de la vierge ici et ça toujours été un
haut lieu de ce qui fait la beauté de la
cathédrale de chartres c'est celle
architecture d'abord et puis cette
extraordinaire ensemble de vitraux sont
pas tous très très beau mais qui donne
une lumière unique au monde suivant les
heures suivant les ciels suivant la
qualité de la lumière en hiver en était
le matin de bonne heure le soir on peut
dire que le presque toute la peinture
moderne était dans la cathédrale enfin
j'ai vu j'ai vu deux structures à
l'alléger dans le porche royal j'ai vu
parfois des tendresses à la bonne heure
c'est une remise en question de l'homme
qui se fait dans cette cathédrale c'est
ça n'est pas de l'esthétisme c'est du
grand spirituel
nous nous trouvons ici devant l'un des
vitraux les plus célèbres de la
cathédrale levitra dit de la belle
verrière dont le centre est du 12e
siècle avec ces bleus plus clair et en
arrangements du xiiie siècle très
heureux était fait autour avec des bleus
plus sombres qui met en valeur la la
merveilleuse limpidité du verre du 12e
siècle la qualité de ce ver du 12e et
extraordinaire puisque iraient ils
résistent encore maintenant à la
pollution
mais il est évident que depuis qu'on a
installé le 12 au pétrole on assiste
depuis dix ou quinze ans à une
accélération de la de la crasse sur les
vitraux à tel titre que par exemple
l'admirable visage et mes vêtements du
petit jésus là qui est sur les genoux de
sa mère sont complètement invisible les
monuments historiques ont fait le
rapport suivant les conférenciers
maintenant n'arrivent plus à donner mais
leur conférence achard parce qu'il ya
des mes panneaux entier dont on ne peut
plus expliqué la signification alors ça
c'est un phénomène tout nouveau il ya
encore cinquante nouvelles loire ça
s'accélère de plus en plus baissier ou
fait rien d'une façon très proche on va
insister vraiment à l'obscurcissement
total de la cathédrale
alors la riposte la riposte des
monuments historiques
ça a été de d'abord de réfléchir sur ce
qu'on peut faire on a opté pour une
méthode qui est celle au royal qui est
une méthode de pétrochimie et qui
devaient être étendues à tous les micros
de france
ce film de pétrochimie qui avait été
promis à un destin peu plus intenses
puisque au départ il était question
presque de 50 mille mètres carrés de
vitraux française défendue par la même
méthode s'avérait aussi une un danger un
autre vie en danger encore pour les
vitraux puisque la l'humidité travers
sans détruire la pétrochimie
le film et sera alors là un danger
absolu pour les verts et il faut qu'on
sache que dans dix ans il faudra enlever
ce produit nous nous trouvons devant un
siècle qui va être hélas de par ses
difficultés à conserver dans une
atmosphère polluée aussi bien les
sculptures du reste que les vitraux et
nous nous sommes donnés comme tâche
d'abord de faire l'étude est d'alerter
le gouvernement sur les danger qu'il y
aurait à employer telle ou telle méthode
est à chercher avec les laboratoires
aussi bien français qu'étrangers
la méthode qui sembleraient la meilleure
enfin pour l'instant seul qui n'est pas
encore au point mais qui pourrait être
prometteuse qui va être employé ici même
à la restauration café l'atelier le rhin
à saint-pierre de charte
la protection avec un double vitrage
ce qui pose encore des problèmes la
question des condensations intérieur
n'est pas n'est pas encore tout à fait
au point je pense qu'on doit y arriver
il ya des exemples en allemagne où il ya
des protections à double vitrage qui
date de 1860 je croyais qu'ils ont donné
de bonnes solutions
le prochain jeu d'oeuvres dont nous vous
parlerons sera vézelay 1er mai ensuite
samedi dimanche un pont un week end le
demander à laurent brevet de nous dire
comment il voit la météo
et quand je dis comment ils la voient ce
matin il faisait de l'avion avec l'aéro
club d'antenne 2 et il a tout vu en tous
les cas du ciel commence à se creuser
écoutez dans le ciel des chars venaient
ce matin près de paris le ciel était
bleu et il y avait peu de vent ce qui
prouve que nous sommes dans une zone de
boutons l anticyclone ses terres est
stable le beau temps va continuer en
revanche il y avait de la brume la
visibilité n'était pas très bon il y
aura encore de la brune demain samedi et
dimanche
enfin il y avait des courants ascendants
d'air ça signifie deux choses d'une part
que le sol de la terre est en train de
chauffer les températures général vont
remonter les jours prochains enfin ce
courant ascendant forme des grands
nuages le soir qu'on appelle des cumulus
où les cumulonimbus c'est dire qu'il y
aura de nombreux orages dans les
prochains jours sur la france la carte
avec précision maintenant et par région
d'abord nord bassin parisien nord-est un
peu frais le matin un peu brumeux mais
soleil ensuite mais le soir formation le
ctu mouna bus et des orages
nord nord-est et bassin parisien orages
localisés sans grande gravité nord-ouest
maintenant botton également est
toutefois plus de nuages sur les côtes
de la manche et de la mer du nord mais
ça s'améliorera dans la journée enfin
moitié sud du pays botton également un
peu brumeux dans les vallées de
l'intérieur le matin ensoleillé ensuite
sauf dans l'extrême sud est de la corse
au sud des alpes
il y aura encore beaucoup de nuages des
risques de pluie des pluies orageuses
samedi bien sûr tirer ses symboles car
je pense que ça s'améliorera dans ces
régions qui se mettront au diapason du
reste du pays avec donc du beau temps
brumeux le matin aura lieu le soir ça
devrait continuer dimanche
un dernier mot les températures
température vous le voyez prévue pour
demain en hausse lagence pour les
économies d'énergie conseille d'arrêter
le chauffage sauf dans quatre régions la
bretagne le jura les vosges et
l'auvergne où elle reste encore un petit
peu fraîche mais là aussi fera quand
même beau et chaud même religion est
terminée et ce soir vers 23 heures c'est
hervé claude qui vous donnera les
dernières informations de la journée
demain antenne de midi avec patrick
lecocq
bonsoir merci et peut-être m